hey rich this is kevin from san
francisco bay area
i'm a fan of the gospel that you're
spreading and i really appreciate your
recent episode with matthew walker on
sleep i have a question that i think you
are uniquely positioned to help answer
see sometimes i'll do an intense workout
at around noonish
i'll run bike swim or do some at home
p90x which i'll burn a lot of calories
so immediately after my workout i'll
have a high calorie plant-based recovery
smoothie like one of the recipes in the
plant-power way
and then a little later i'll eat some
other foods and meals like a big bowl of
oatmeal and
later another huge bowl of salad for
dinner and many times
i'll also sneak in a large veggie
smoothie i try to focus on consuming as
much leafy greens and micronutrients as
possible while also trying to get in my
needed macros
but also not trying to overdo my macros
too much as i tend to gain weight pretty
easily
however sometimes it seems like i'm not
consuming enough calories because once
it gets time for bed
i'll feel pretty full mostly because of
all the greens that i've consumed
but then over time while i'm in bed my
body will feel light jittery and hungry
to the point that i'll need to get out
of bed and go to the kitchen and eat
something more
only now that i've eaten a plant-based
late night snack
the fiber in that vegan snack starts to
churn in my digestive system
including smoothies which prevents me
from further being able to fall asleep
it's kind of this catch-22 scenario
anyway thank you rich awesome
yes story of my life kevin story
of my life really yeah
because because i immediately thought
he's just not eating enough calories
yeah well i think that's a huge part of
it like he's just eating too much salad
oatmeal you burn through that stuff yeah
i think that i think he's under i think
he's
because he was obese and he lost all
this weight and he's trying to be
first of all thank you for your question
kevin i love this question um
because he's he's formerly obese and
he's trying to be really diligent about
his nutrition going forward and so
cautious and afraid of putting on weight
because of that past experience that
he's under fueling himself because he's
terrified of putting on weight
but what he's doing is he is not getting
enough calories and that's
creating the agitation that's leading to
the sleep problem
it's an interesting thing i've
experienced this myself
and you know all all the the thing is
all the science supports not eating
right before bed right not supposed to
eat right before you go to bed right
supposed to eat hours before
if i eat like three hours before bedtime
and then i go to bed
inevitably i will either be unable to
fall asleep or i'll or i'll wake up like
two or three hours later and have to go
into the kitchen and eat more really
all the time so that has led to an
unhealthy habit of eating close
to my bedtime which isn't great because
then
as your body is digesting the food when
it's done with that digestive process
you end up waking up like
wake up at like three right i've played
with this so many different ways so
i feel you kevin i relate to this um
you know i'm also you know i wasn't
formerly obese i was heavier but i'm
conscious of my caloric intake
so i tend to eat light during the day
and then have a larger dinner
but i've had that same experience of
lying in bed awake hungry unable to
sleep
all the stuff i don't have a magic
bullet for this
but two things one is the thing we
already mentioned which is i think that
you really are
under-fueled and that sense of fullness
isn't due
to you meeting your caloric needs it's
because you're eating this super
fibrous very bloaty stuff right floaty
stuff that gives you the sensation of
being
full and is great because it will
prevent you from overeating
and it you know basically turns off that
appetite mechanism
but all those leafy greens all of that
fiber
very high in the micronutrients and the
phytochemicals and all those things that
you want
but at the same time if you're working
out as hard as you're working out like
you've got to put food in your system
yeah
and when your smoothies aren't good
enough when you're not eating meat and
dairy which tend to be
incredibly calorically dense foods
that's this is a common
thing with people who go plant-based
they're like i'm always hungry and it's
like well you used to eat like
burgers and you know milkshakes and now
you're eating
salads and quinoa like you're gonna
you're gonna have to eat a lot more than
you're used to eating and because if
you're eating it in a whole food way
like there is all that extra fiber so
you'll feel full but you're actually not
you know not getting sufficient calories
right and your body is like i'm trying
to repair myself like i'm the agitation
like that
that kind of shakiness that you get is
your body trying to tell you that you
need to eat more
the other thing that i think it could be
helpful for you
is that i found and this is purely
anecdotal but i found personally that
when i eat more throughout the day
that's helpful so with this you know
penchant that i have for eating light
throughout the day
sometimes that will lead to this problem
at night even if i eat a big dinner
but when i'm when i'm eating you know
when i'm not like doing an intermittent
fast or whatever and i'm eating
throughout the day and i eat a decent
lunch and all of that
then i can eat a decent dinner and i'll
find myself
less in less of a struggle to to go
to go to sleep so larger portions eaten
consistently and earlier throughout the
day will will i think
help ameliorate that um
yeah because what you're talking about
here is working out really hard then
having a smoothie
than having a bowl of oatmeal and a
salad like to me like
like that's just not enough right food i
think that's right yeah cause
because i'll have oatmeal in the morning
before even before
a run or like an hour or so before right
he didn't talk about anything that he
eats before noon so i don't know if he's
not eating before noon or he's eating a
breakfast that he just didn't
tell us about who knows but like you
know that
i i'm not telling anyone what to eat i'm
not in that business but
pasta is a very filling thing that could
be good if you're if you need
carb i know i know it's well i don't
know how controversial it is to eat
pasta wouldn't be the first thing i
recommend pasta is very effective if you
eat that right before you go to bed
you'll pass out
right because all the blood goes to your
belly to digest this food
you'll wake up at three o'clock in the
morning don't even say i don't know if
it's
you know it will do the trick in terms
of getting you to fall asleep not sure
that's the best practice
but perhaps you know get over this fear
of macros
and start you know eating
complex carbohydrates that are satiating
you can eat potatoes you can eat sweet
potatoes you can eat
long grain rice like there's plenty of
curries beans and rice
yeah tons of beans yeah i eat gigantic
gigantic bowls of beans and rice
my kids still like they'll get pla you
know we go to the dinner table they
get their normal plates out and i'll go
and i'll get the giant like salad bowl
and then i put my dinner in that and
they laugh every time but
i just feel like i have to eat more so
you know
eat avocados like that's tom brady eats
drinks avocados you can eat avocados
right and i think
you know i think there is a little bit
of a block here because of that fear of
gaining weight
and maybe you know maybe you need to
you know in letting go of that be okay
with putting on a little bit of weight
as you
as you figure this out for yourself
because what you want to do
is is have the weight come off the right
way so it stays off
but if you're constantly starving and
not sleeping well
because you're afraid of putting on
weight you're not going to sustain this
anyway
you're going to end up lapsing back into
some unhealthy habits alexi mulchanov
once told me years ago the great
freediver world record holder
said it's not the number of that's on
the scale
it's it's it's how it's okay to have a
bigger number
if it's if you're fit right fitness and
fitness
fitness and the and the number on the
scale are two separate things you don't
have to
they don't mean the same thing good
point
yeah um final thought uh for kevin is to
and he didn't talk about this at all
which i think he which is instructive
that he didn't bring it up but
i'm curious about what his pre-sleep
routine is
like perhaps there's some work that you
could do around
setting yourself up for a good night of
sleep like
are you having a magnesium tea at night
are you avoiding
those screens do you take a bath you
know maybe take a warm bath like an hour
before you go to bed
do them do an evening meditation listen
to
you know get the call map out and listen
to a sleep story
like part of this might also be
induced by anxiety like what what part
of this is
is is more of a mental emotional thing
and what part of it is
actually a physiological response to his
food intake so if all else fails
listen to roll-on yeah go right out
right get a tent
cold air in the room get a face mask a
gravity blanket
yes the world is your oyster kevin and
david attenborough
you know he puts me right to sleep there
you go yeah there's certain people
right nature sounds whatever does it for
you
um cool but hey thanks for the question
that was helpful thank you kevin
[Music]
you